[Musik]
millionenhilfen für gut eine
internationale geberkonferenz verspricht
dem libanon unterstützung dort geht der
protest gegen die regierung weiter
präsidentschaftswahl in belarus viele
weißrussen hoffen auf veränderung nach
26 jahren und er machte aber lukaschenko
reifenpoker in silverstone max
verstappen gewinnt den jubiläums grand
prix vor dem silberpfeil duo hamilton
waters
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
unserem nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag
auch damit sport und norbert lehmann
junior von mir nach der
explosionskatastrophe drohte libanon nun
auch in eine massive politische krise zu
stürzen
der start scheint derzeit kaum
handlungsfähig zu sein
nun beeilte sich die internationale
gemeinschaft zu helfen frankreichs
präsident mag organisierte zusammen mit
der uno eine geberkonferenz um geld für
medizin nahrung und wiederaufbau
einzusammeln
200 millionen euro kamen zusammen sagte
aussenminister maß dem zdf lockt
wallbott der sonntag begann ruhig heute
in beirut nach den schweren
zusammenstößen gestern zwischen
demonstranten und sicherheitskräften
während die bürger weiter die trümmer
beseitigen hoffen viele libanesen auf
hilfe aus dem ausland einer
internationalen geber videokonferenz-
mahnte frankreichs staatspräsident makro
dringende politische und finanzielle
reformen an
wir müssen gemeinsam alles unternehmen
um gewalt und chaos zu verhindern
die vereinten nationen sollen die
hilfslieferungen koordinieren
deutschland wird sich nach einer ersten
soforthilfe von zehn millionen euro
mit weiteren 20 millionen euro
beteiligen das geld so außenminister maß
komme internationalen organisationen
zugute
mit dem wir sehr sehr lange
zusammenarbeiten und bei denen wir uns
auch sehr sicher sind dass das geld da
ankommt wo es hin soll nämlich bei den
leuten die in not sind in beirut
unterdessen wollen die leidgeprüften die
bahn ihren druck auf die herrschende
klasse des landes weiter
aufrechterhalten
am frühen abend versammelten sich wieder
tausende im zentrum beiruts um zu
protestieren
die menschen sind wütend und sie werden
nicht nachgeben
im kampf gegen diese politiker die
libanon und beruht so zerstört habe in
den straßen rund um das
parlamentsgebäude begannen einzelne
gruppen steine gegen amtsgebäude zu
werfen
die sicherheitskräfte setzten tränengas
und gummigeschosse ein um die menge
zurück zu bringen
die spd ist grundsätzlich offen für ein
bündnis mit der linkspartei im bund das
sagte spd chef walter borjans der funke
mediengruppe auch vizekanzler scholz und
die co-vorsitzende esken sehen das so in
einem künftigen regierungsbündnis wolle
man den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
in den mittelpunkt stellen so
walter-borjans die große koalition sei
dafür keine grundlage
wie hält es die afd mit dem
rechtsextremismus die frage ist zur
zerreißprobe geworden für die partei
ebenso wie ihre haltung zu den
schutzmaßnahmen gegen korona themen im
zdf sommerinterview mit afg chef
kinogruppe david gebhard berichtet seit
monaten ringt die ard beim thema corona
um eine einheitliche linie im
zdf-sommerinterview spricht sich afg
chef timo grub aller gegen eine masken
pflicht haus wir sagen es ausdrücklich
dass wir auf die freiwilligkeit auch das
masken tragens wert legen wir sagen
nicht an masken pflicht wir leben auch
eine masken pflicht zum beispiel im
schulunterricht ab massive kritik an der
eigenen führung gab es zuletzt von afg
abgeordneten aus der bundestagsfraktion
ein zitat der wähler bemerkt es schon
und ich warte nur auf den moment wo uns
alt parteien und medien dann final
entlarvt haben werden das ist nicht
irgendein externer kritiker das ist
einer ihrer abgeordneten das ist eine
meinung ja aber jahrelang wir sind wir
sind eine wir sind eine
oppositionspartei wir sind natürlich
auch eine demokratische parteien der
alle meinung auch interne meinung das
ist eine interne meinung die sie jetzt
grad zitieren die wir natürlich auch zum
anlass nehmen in cannes zu diskutieren
auch der rauswurf von andreas kalbitz
spaltet seit monaten die fdp parteichef
morton attestiert diesem eine verfestigt
rechtsextreme vor vita kallwitz hatte in
der vergangenheit mehrmals neonazi
gruppen besucht es gibt sehr wohl
menschen die sich ändern können
und das muss man ihnen auch teil sehr
kalt ist gelogen hat bei seinem
parteieintritt in dieser organisation
angehört denn wird er natürlich aus der
partei ausgeschlossen entgegen der
mehrheit des eigenen parteivorstands
wilco parteichef kubala auch heute nicht
mit kalbitz brechen er will erst mal die
weitere juristische prüfung abwarten
das ganze interview können sie gleich im
anschluss an diese nachrichten bei uns
sehen
in afghanistan sind
friedensverhandlungen zwischen regierung
und taliban näher gerückt die große
ratsversammlung loja dschirga stimmte zu
auch die restlichen 400 gefangenen
taliban frei zu lassen
damit gilt die letzte forderung der
islamistischen gruppe als erfüllt die
friedensgespräche sollen nach
informationen westlicher diplomaten
demnächst in doha beginnen nach belarus
auch bekannt als weißrussland wo knapp
sieben millionen menschen aufgerufen
waren bei der präsidentschaftswahl ihre
stimme abzugeben
staatschef alexander lukaschenko strebt
seine sechste amtszeit an
seit 26 jahren führt er das land
autoritär
die hoffnung der opposition liegt auf
swetlana cichowski auch im namen ihres
mannes antritt der populäre blogger war
zu beginn seines wahlkampfs verhaftet
worden und seit wenigen minuten sind die
wahllokale geschlossen daher die frage
an unsere korrespondentin für übergab
hat die opposition mit svetlana sich
allofs kaya denn überhaupt eine chance
das ist wirklich schwer zu sagen denn
belastbarer unabhängige zahlen die gibt
es aus belarus so gut wie gar nicht eine
ehe regierungskritische organisation
hatte im laufe des tages
nachwahlbefragungen veröffentlicht
wonach die kanus kajaks knapp 70 prozent
der wählerstimmen kam und lukaschenko
ungefähr auf 16
gerade erreichen uns die ersten
hochrechnungen aus - und da
sagt die zentrale wahlkommission es sei
genau andersrum lukaschenko kommt auf
etwa etwas über 70 prozent und die
hannover liegt weit abgeschlagen
dahinter was man zur zeit mit sicherheit
sagen kann ist dass fanatiker of skye ja
wirklich eine große welle der
mobilisierung losgetreten hat sie hat
die hoffnung in wahnsinnig viele
belarussen geweckt dass sich nach 26
jahren lukaschenko endlich etwas ändern
könnte und diese mobilisierung die wurde
auch heute am wahltag sehr deutlich denn
die schlangen vor den wahllokalen
die waren wahnsinnig lang und an manchen
orten da sollen sogar die stimmzettel
ausgegangen sein weil so viele menschen
ihre stimme abgeben wollten
vielen dank für ihre einschätzung ihre
informationen für bewerber das aus
weißrussland in deutschland ist die zahl
der korona neuinfektion nach mehreren
tagen wieder unter die schwelle von 1000
gesunken
das robert koch institut meldet 555 neue
fälle allerdings übermitteln am
wochenende auch weniger gesundheitsämter
ihre daten im schnitt der vergangenen
sieben tage haben sich laut johns
hopkins universität 840 menschen neu
angesteckt gestern waren es 830
dramatisch ist die korona lage in
brasilien das land zählt jetzt mehr als
hunderttausend todesopfer
allein in den vergangenen 24 stunden
starben mehr als 900 menschen in
verbindung mit cupid 19 präsident ball
so nahe hatte die währungskrise immer
wieder heruntergespielt
brasilien ist nach den usa am
schlimmsten von der pandemie betroffen
in den usa liegt die zahl der
infizierten inzwischen bei über 5
millionen nach den gescheiterten
verhandlungen über ein weiteres corona
hilfspaket hat präsident trump per
dekret verschiedene massnahmen
angeordnet
trump will unter anderem die
lohnnebenkosten senken und den zuschlag
zur arbeitslosenhilfe verlängern
ob er das allerdings einfach anordnen
darf bis juristisch umstritten
ja und nun zu die erneuert und zum
zweiten tag der deutschen
leichtathletik-meisterschaften in
braunschweig bei 36 grad im schatten
ganz schön schweißtreibend heute im
mittelpunkt weitsprung weltmeisterin
maleike amiando
die sportlerin des jahres tritt zum
ersten mal in diesem sommer in ihrer
gold disziplin an und wurde souverän zum
vierten mal deutsche meisterin endlich
wieder weit fliegen nach der
rückenverletzung im winter in
braunschweig nur aus verkürztem anlauf
16 schritte sechs meter 71 firma leica
mambo und das break perfekt getroffen
dieses jahr hat einfach nicht den
stellenwert ich hatte in der
vorbereitung jetzt viel zeit genommen um
eine rückenverletzung auszuprobieren
wenn sich nur noch die virus gefahr
bahne ließe dann könnte sie ihren traum
leben vom training mit carl lewis in den
usa max verstappen hat die mercedes
erfolg jährige stopp beim formel 1
jubiläums grand prix in silverstone
siegte der red bull pilot vor
weltmeister lewis hamilton der
niederländer mit der besseren
reifenstrategie überholt kurz nach
seinem ersten stopp den führenden bottas
und fährt von startplatz vier zum sieg
weltmeister hamilton holt sich kurz vor
rennende platz zwei vor teamkollege
potters bester deutscher nico hülkenberg
als siebter ferrari pilot sebastian
vettel dreht sich in runde eins später
nach einem verpatzten boxenstopp seltene
öffentliche team kritik über funk ich
hänge hier fest ihr wisst dass ihr es
verbockt habt platz 12 und neue ferrari
zoff bayern münchen ist durch den sieg
gegen chelsea gestern abend souverän ins
champions-league-viertelfinale
eingezogen
robert lewandowski der zweifache
torschütze per foulelfmeter in der
zehnten und dann per kopf zum 4 2 1
endstand in der 84 minute das team von
trainer hansi flick trifft nun am
freitag im finalturnier in lissabon auf
den fc barcelona bayern gegen barca
das ist ein echter fußballer freuen uns
und noch der blick aufs wetter und die
frage bleiben die temperaturen derart
hoch offensichtlich ja an den küsten und
im süden wieder sehr sonnig ansonsten
mehr wolken und einzelne schauer zum
nachmittag im osten hitzegewitter 28 bis
36 grad und zur zeit gelten
unwetterwarnungen für das nördliche
nordrhein-westfalen marietta slomka
begrüßt sie um drei viertel 10 im heute
journal
wir sagen tschüss und wünschen noch
einen entspannten sonntagabend